[inaudible].
All right,
so let's shift to the environment.
If you listen to the news,
it's getting hotter or everybody's freaking out about everything.
We don't have clean water.
All of these things
calm me down.
Well,
I don't want to get into a debate on the internal debate over over the signs of,
of global warming.
I'll leave it to the specialist.
Um,
certainly I do acknowledge that there is a consensus that the world is warming.
Uh,
whether it is warming at a,
uh,
at a too high a rate or a lukewarming rate and where it's heading.
Uh,
obviously prediction of the future is that,
that's the most difficult thing.
I'm going to leave that to,
to a specialist center sign.
Yeah.
Just very quickly on that though,
is it possible that in some of the places that it's warming,
it's actually good that,
that
it's warming?
Well,
a,
suddenly there's this,
uh,
there's one scientist from Holland called a professor tall,
has a calculated,
uh,
the,
the likely costs and benefits of global warming until 2080 or so.
And he thought that,
uh,
um,
because of the growing,
uh,
because of the longer growing season we'll be able to actually bring in,
more,
uh,
more food,
grow,
grow more food.
We also thought that,
uh,
there's also some evidence that the world is greening as a result of more co two
in the atmosphere.
But I do acknowledge I want to make it very,
yeah.
Any hate mail to you or to me,
I want to go into get hate mail either way,
but acknowledge way.
I want to yeah.
Acknowledge
that.
Uh,
uh,
there are serious concerns.
Um,
uh,
and,
and I'm,
I'm basically a guy who is a techno optimist.
I want to look for solutions to these problems,
uh,
rather than what I don't want to do is to start economic development.
I don't want to stop economic development in developing countries because it's
extremely important that,
that people who are very,
very poor should not be very,
very poor.
It's very important that if a woman in Angola or in Zambia has a premature
birth,
she should be able to have an access to a,
uh,
to an incubator that is a run on a,
on a,
uh,
on an electricity grid that is not going to collapse,
for example,
okay.
That,
uh,
that people care can air condition their homes,
let's say in Africa or they can,
they can keep themselves warm in a,
in Argentina basically,
that,
that is my,
my goal not to stop economic development,
um,
those particularly of true of,
of,
of poor countries.
Uh,
but I also think that,
uh,
it applies to rich countries.
Um,
if,
if we can make life more comfortable for people.
I,
I see,
no,
uh,
I think it would be very difficult,
especially within the democratic context context to stop that.
Now look at what's in,
uh,
in macrons Paris.
We've seen
riots.
Yeah.
That country has and hasn't seen since the 1960s.
Why is that?
That's because the environmental concerns of the French elite Macron included,
are bumping against,
uh,
the,
living standards and limitations on the living standards of ordinary French men
and women.
If you increase the price of electricity,
uh,
dramatically in order to make people cut down on electricity,
it's also going to reduce their,
their,
both their comfort,
but also their standard of living.
If you're going to put additional taxes on this,
that,
and the other cars,
uh,
gasoline,
what have you,
uh,
eventually people are going to get upset and are going to start voting for some
very unpleasant people.
And this is something that we see happening throughout Europe.
Now.
There are many different reasons why people vote for,
um,
uh,
for unpleasant,
of political parties.
But,
uh,
a fundamental feeling that that standards of living in Europe,
arts stagnating and that they are being taxed to a point where they actually
have to go out and protest in the streets,
burn,
uh,
hundreds of cars and basically vandalized the arc de Triomphe of themselves.
So these things are happening.
So what I want to do is to sort of navigate a middle course between,
uh,
between concerns over the environment,
and uh,
and,
uh,
and continued economic development and continued prosperity.
And I think that the answer could potentially be found in techno optimism,
as I would call it.
So I would consider a fracking to be a good example of techno optimism.
Okay.
Uh,
burning of one unit of natural gas produces half as much co two emissions as
burning of coal.
So I think it would make a lot of sense to burn more natural gas than coal.
But
our friends on the environmental side hate that because it's still fossil fuels.
Okay.
So let's forget about fossil fuels.
Let's have nuclear energy.
Okay.
Last time anybody has died from a nuclear accident,
it was in Chernobyl,
um,
because the communist leadership,
uh,
cut corners when it came to the safety and,
there was a breakdown of,
of,
um,
chain of command and whatever.
And there wasn't this,
this accident where a,
where dozens of people died,
but since then,
not a single person has died as a result of nuclear accidents,
including in Fukushima,
which is the most recent one.
Um,
so nuclear energy is a perfect example of producing a lot of energy,
uh,
without any CEO.
Two emissions are our friends are in the environmentalist movement,
please.
No,
they are not.
Let's take another example.
Um,
uh,
say a photo Lizer let's say that we can genetically engineer crops to need less
fertilizer and less pesticides.
Why do we want a less fertilizer,
endless pesticides?
Because when those flow into rivers and then into oceans,
that can have a negative consequence for wildlife.
So ideally we would like to use less fertilizer,
less pesticide.
So imagine that through Gmos,
uh,
through genetic engineering,
we could produce crops that,
uh,
that,
that don't require pesticides and fertilizer.
Are Our friends in the environmental,
I'll be happy.
No,
they hate that.
They hate those three letters until the time that we offer as techno optimists,
we offer a gradual move in the right direction,
which cumulatively could have a massive impact on quality of life,
on,
uh,
environmental protection and so forth.
Um,
you know,
the,
the answer is always no.
So what,
so it's interesting because when,
when you started talking about this,
there's this immediate hesitancy because I think everyone,
if you talk about climate at all,
people think you're going to get slammed.
And I can tell you the most hate that I ever got on the show is when I had Alex
Epstein who wrote a book called the moral case for fossil fuels in there.
Uh,
he wasn't denying climate science.
He was,
you're saying that fossil fuels,
in his estimation,
are still the best way to advance human prosperity going forward.
So it's interesting you,
you immediately said you didn't want to go too far down that road because it
just opens up the heat and all that.
But,
but the,
in essence,
what you're saying is that we're having to fight the environmentalist's on what
you would prescribe as the best ways to move the environment forward.
That that's pretty fascinating.
So how do you get through to these people then?
I,
well,
I don't know,
I'm trying,
what are the things I'm trying to explain to a lot of my friends is that
actually prosperity and economic development can be a friend of the environment.
That's because of this concept of environmental Kuznets curve.
Now that's just a fancy way of saying that when people grow old richer,
they are willing to spend more money on clean environment and protection of
animals.
How do I know that?
Because in,
well it's not just stats which show it,
but also look at the real life examples.
When the economy collapsed in Zimbabwe,
the first thing that people did in order to survive was to start slaughtering
animals in the wild,
shooting zebras for meat,
shooting elephants for tusks.
Um,
and,
and the environment took a huge knock in Venezuela when the economy collapsed.
Both socialist countries by the way.
But you never mind.
In Venezuela when the economy collapsed,
uh,
people started slaughtering animals in the zoo.
The only way you can survive if it's a choice between the life of an antelope
and the survival of your child,
you know exactly what to do.
And so economic development,
making people richer,
it's actually,
um,
uh,
a very good way of accomplishing this environmental co causing,
it's kind of when people grow rich,
they start caring about the air they breathe,
they start caring about a welfare of animals and so on and so forth because
those are from the perspective of the survival of the human being,
luxury goods.
And we are already seeing some very interesting things happening around the
world.
For example,
the forest coverage of,
uh,
of,
of the Oris is still declining by about 0.08% per year,
but it is declining primarily if not exclusively in poor countries and
especially in Africa and also Latin America.
But it is increasing in a rich countries.
Uh,
I,
for a station is taking place that are more for us to being grown.
And in China,
we are seeing huge amount of our forests station because the country is now
richer than what did you used to be.
So through economic development,
we can do that through our economy development.
We can also,
um,
uh,
we can also start protecting more of our marine life,
um,
by creating exclusion zones,
uh,
against fishing and so forth.
How can we do that?
Why is that connected to economic development?
Well,
because if you,
for example,
you can,
uh,
well not only do you have more technological,
um,
uh,
ways of monitoring who is breaking the rules,
but also you can still get access to the food you want through aquaculture.
Okay.
So,
uh,
countries which are richer are able to,
are able to get their food from a,
from aquaculture rather than from,
uh,
from ordinary,
shore fishing.
So when,
when it comes to these solutions,
which by the way,
I mean,
what you just said there,
it's pretty mind blowing that in much of the world it's getting greener.
You know,
I mean,
that's,
people just don't think about that.
We just sorted,
just don't accept that.
That's real.
Most of this,
do you see that we have to have a sort of public and private partnership on how
we move forward on these things?
Should most of this come from governments?
Should it come from private corporations?
Should it come from individual people?
I mean,
that seems to be what a lot of the debate is also about.
Well,
uh,
I think that the research that the um,
evidence,
uh,
for the efficacy of a government spending when it comes to science,
um,
when it comes to scientific research for example,
is not all that persuasive.
I don't think that governments are particularly good at spending money on
scientific research.
Um,
meaning that the researcher shoddy or just that they throw money at things and
then just nothing comes of it.
Um,
yeah,
that,
that would be,
that will be part of the reason.
Um,
I am a believer in,
uh,
in,
private companies are doing their own research,
um,
driven by the profit motive.
For example,
um,
energy inputs into production of anything from a can of coke,
two bottle of water.
Uh,
our costs money.
A companies actually do have a,
an incentive at profit incentive to try to limit the amount of resources they
use in order to produce any type of good.
Um,
in the 1970s,
uh,
between 1970s and today,
the number of cans of coke that you could get from a pound of aluminum has
actually increased by something like 40%.
That's because companies don't want to spend money.
They don't have to spend on electricity,
uh,
on,
spending money on natural resources and oil and raw materials and wood heavy.
And so what we are actually seeing is that,
uh,
the number of dark dollars,
um,
uh,
per,
um,
what the,
the amount of the amount of energy,
uh,
we need in order to produce a dollar of output is actually declining.
And that that's happening naturally through the process of profit maximization
on the parts of,
of corporations.
Now that doesn't mean that there is absolutely no need for any kind of
regulations.
We don't want corporations to be,
to be dumping toxic materials in our pristine rivers and what have you.
But,
uh,
but what I am saying is that,
is that uh,
corporations in search for profit,
um,
are actually very good at coming up with innovative solutions to environmental
problems.
Yeah.
It's part of the problem here also that different countries that are at
different stages of their evolution of their economies and everything else need
different things,
need wildly different things.
What's happening in China now with growth is very different than what's
happening in the United States or India or any of these countries that now half,
half to that are often putting out more co two and emissions and things like
that.
They're going through their industrial revolutions.
We already did it so that we have an unequal playing field when it comes to some
of them.
Yes.
Um,
so that is a well known,
uh,
notion within the economic development that uh,
as a country starts on a pass through industrialization,
it's them actually environment increases.
But once again,
it reaches that,
uh,
that inflection point and then it starts to decrease as people become rich
enough to start to appreciate,
um,
nice environment.
Um,
90% of the plastics that are entering our oceans come from eight reverse.
They're all in the developing world,
in Africa and in Asia.
Uh,
the contribution of western advanced economies to plastic pollution of the
oceans is negligible,
um,
precisely because we are able to spend more money and effort and thought on how
not to do it.
What would you say to the people that would say,
uh,
our time is up here,
or the evolution of humanity is that we've got to go to the stars,
that eventually we'll have to get off this,
this mortal coil and do it again somewhere else.
Well,
first of all,
it is very important to remember that a pessimism about humanity's future,
uh,
has been with us since the,
since the dawn of writing,
um,
from,
from antiquity and ancient poems and epics,
you know,
the,
after all the flood,
what is it about the flight is about closing the world's population that,
that,
uh,
that went,
ra,
um,
the Cato,
the elder,
uh,
writing second century BC thoughts that Rome was finished because,
um,
you know,
uh,
the,
the young were corrupted and,
uh,
um,
women had loose morals and men wear to a feminine to fight wars.
And this is when Rome was just a small town in the,
you know,
with fewer,
with a few provinces in Italy,
Rome continue to expand for the next three to 400 years.
Um,
but he,
he was just very early.
He was just very early.
But,
but you can see,
every generation thinks that,
that,
that we are,
especially as we grow older,
we think that,
uh,
the world is entering a period of decline.
Whereas in fact,
what do we do?
We are projecting our own physical decline,
uh,
onto the world.
But so far those,
uh,
those warnings about the imminent collapse of humanity of all it has been proven
wrong as,
um,
uh,
Thomas Babington Nikolay,
in 19th century British politician and the writer has written that on what basis
is it without having seen all this progress that we have made behind us.
We see nothing but misery in front of us.
I'm paraphrasing,
but that's the essence of what he said and I think he's absolutely right.
Yeah.
So we've,
we've done this diseases,
we're eradicating,
we're doing a lot of good on the environment or at least have,
have some options.
Now we do have options.
Yes.
Yeah.
Uh,
what else,
what else should we be hitting on to give people some,
some positivity to think about?
Well,
I think,
um,
my pet peeve is a,
that I think that,
uh,
people don't read enough history,
aren't enough versed in,
uh,
in,
in history how life really used to be like,
uh,
before.
Um,
and I wish that people would spend more time thinking about what they are doing
on their base daily basis.
And asking themselves,
uh,
would I be able to do this in the past?
Um,
I just had a crown have put in or a root canal operation with anesthetic.
And it was,
it was not something and there wasn't a particularly pleasant.
Um,
but,
but yeah,
but it was better than it would have been a hundred years ago.
A hundred or 200 years ago.
You would have it,
you know,
um,
uh,
somebody would have to pull it out of your,
out of your mouth.
Um,
and,
um,
so,
so that's one thing.
Uh,
I think that people,
uh,
and I think that if people understand history better and how life truly was
quite horrific until very recent times,
again,
we have 300,000 years old,
but at the time of abundance,
it's roughly 200 years old,
250 years old.
Maybe there will be more grateful and,
um,
uh,
for the things that we have and hopefully they will be more appreciative and
more supporting of the institutions which underpin a modernity,
liberal democracy with all of its warts,
with all of its imperfections.
Uh,
it is still functioning better than a Putin's Russia or,
or Erdogan's Turkey.
A free market.
Capitalism does have its problems.
Yes.
Um,
we shouldn't socialize costs of banking for example,
and prioritized and privatized gains from Wall Street banking.
Um,
but again,
it is the best.
It is the best creative wealth known to humankind.
And so throwing it out because there are imperfections on the margins that we
should be working on to,
to,
to improve would be a great mistake.
Um,
so yes,
appreciation of the past,
gratitude for the present,
hopefulness for the future.
Um,
those are the steps in,
I think,
in the right direction
that my friend is an a plus ending to an interview and for more on Marion and
the incredible work that think progress is doing.
You guys can check out,
think progress.org.